Monday in the dark he lost power in that
in the building no we didn't fool them
this is the 0.35 Gaddafi the zero and
shadow to Justin Ren because I had his
lanterns in the back of my car for just
such an emergency well let's not get
twisted just went game sorry I got a
let's fix that first miraculousness
just writing gave me these lands on the
ground breakdown then you want to Omaha
I use them which I knew you weren't
being left in a car so we need is light
in case and so these lights are usually
used for building and digging wells in
Africa for the poor children but today
they are used for my tent when I hunt
deer yeah but today they're used to line
up the hearts of all the five and get
them
oh that's adorable how would you want to
[ __ ] in the dark no I sure don't I'm not
into that man it's starting to get weird
I don't know I helped dude arteries
mom they're lighter you're not my body I
took gay with me don't get gay into one
skin they did here see their gloves here
they don't every that that study where
they would take strangers men and women
and they would put them in rooms and
they would turn all myself and basically
they would be a little bit in the
beginning they didn't know and they
would have all the lights turn off and
they're doing nobody can see anything
you're doing and nothing you do can be
held against you guys so just charge
different people would knock out no it
would make out that the all kinds of
titty grab and all kind of mass grabbin
but it'd be like mutual these like
college kids though yeah young
good-looking no no no I'm sorry but they
weren't primarily by the week white
middle class too you know younger thing
yeah younger and they made sure haven't
read that study well they sir I don't
think a lot of people have good eyes
mean to make sure there's no I'm not and
I'll find it for you with the study of
kind of figuring out how people behave
with nobody's looking at right so it's
like the honor jar you know a story
where they put will you take a bagel and
this once put a dollar in do you know
when it rains out when it would rain out
people would would cheat on people would
be like you know I'm going it's raining
I'm not going to get my money today how
does that target this past weekend I
some stuff I'm using new house right so
even your little Matt
I cannot [ __ ] here in that and so we
have this part full of stuff chaotic
target there's a million people things
on the lady's doing this you point all
over we have stuff on the bottom and the
total adds up I'm like okay the other
thing and we get to the college of the
receipt just like usual
so I feel like she's been more I don't
do it she missed the big thing on the
bomb she has two things on the top now
now before you had before you hide what
ice at dinner that's odd because before
let me put me in this position so here's
here's how I look at it I look at its
target it's a big machine machine I then
say to myself you know I can walk with
these three things their fridge however
here's what I would work already
overpriced you on everything its target
look I know all the answers
I know and here's the thing I don't want
her to get in trouble okay because she
may have a number based on you know but
the big n it's always based on what she
scanned so her register has to match to
what she scanned so she's out she's out
so the only people getting hurt or just
the machine target the Machine and they
I don't know if they're going to miss
you know three backpacks and stuff so
I'm a and I don't believe in it it's
still fast now to help at some other
degrees out half yeah going off three
hours of sleep in that case I am hungry
yeah in that case in that case I think
that all of us would be forgiven if we
kind of went look and even in your own
brand you're like I and see that though
and I know what I would do I think I did
I don't know I'm trying to what when
push comes to shove I don't know what I
would do I'm gonna say I don't know what
I would do would he follow you what I
think he did is you went see ya and took
off
nope you paid I went back in there then
I said you missed these three things
just oh my gut and I paid cash so they
can they could have got this at all but
I went in that I thought what if they do
see it and she is fired maybe I need
this job
I don't want that that's what you that's
what I wonder got that saw a little
worried about I don't care about the
money girl just know you paid cash so
they can't track value I know but what
happens is yes and she gets fired it was
hot so I went back here shows are you
kidding me on it no you missed these two
chairs and that giant top table on the
knees
oh that's big though always like the
other night okay so each other knowledge
so the next one 600 by around this so I
went back to a guy that gave the cab I
thought you were talking about like an
extra 30 bucks 32 bucks that [ __ ] man so
you know I also I thought yeah a lot of
good things going right now
I got a kid you are Muslim determines a
[ __ ] come as a [ __ ]
I don't you still prepare something
you're good where things are given you
know if you're struggling for me I can
this was a break this time for God yeah
and the cart get outta here that's
different
yes for me I look dude things are too
well well it's unless you're faced with
weird things too like I dropped a rapper
okay in a hallway and I was like I could
eat I don't feel I didn't feel very well
say I don't feel like bending down
picking up that candy wrapper but then I
was like but then somebody else else it
something else has to do it and I was
like I got to do it I got to pick it up
it's a little bit seems like a little
ball you eat on me
anything that Hardy I don't I just don't
want to I don't want to leave any mess
for somebody else to clean him the other
day I was going to get my hair cut
before I said to San Diego the day
before they're gonna accept cash hashtag
Lincoln barbers best in the world all
Mexican barbers and those do a brilliant
job anyway deletes that cash on walked
out and I had like whatever to and
Allah's cash but in just two bills so
two to two $100 bills I want to have my
sweats on Chris get down work it out
$100 bill slipped on out I didn't know I
kept us rang rode my headphones and keep
walking some guy comes up we just pay
man and kind of you know you didn't look
like you're ballin you know you could
tell like you know working in common man
yeah okay you drop this right oh [ __ ]
that's hundred dollars man I didn't grab
that one that's hundred dollars is yeah
you literally talk to back dammit you
don't lose all my dogs I mean you keep
it man
because you find your manner you can
keep it stepped on yeah that's really
cool
goodbye mother no no no don't run store
oh yeah no but that's a good that's a
good man and I think most people would
be that way you want my dad when I was
young and then what give him some [ __ ]
after this and will quit found ourselves
on the back
my dad hanger so I got to start my epics
my dad when I was young I've gone $20
you switch when your kid it's like oh
[ __ ] we go to sizzler pop scrooge mcduck
rich I found $20 in the road up the
street us playing basketball with my
brother my name is weird yet to end
because I was like eight we're the [ __ ]
you get $20 - found it it's almost
dropped up there you go put it back no I
wouldn't do a street song even though I
look in the street or you go put it back
because they might have dude I like it a
Western I like to live on lesson yeah a
little you know it okay
oh we're basking like I crumpled up with
it it wins like yeah now I'm dad is that
we're just still running away now that
how much you just gave me the last
didn't let me keep the $20 so I can get
a giant [ __ ] king-size bag of orders
I've always had a fantasy of coming
across a million dollars in a drug stash
and just being like what making a urine
now you're in the woods or whatever you
are you're like what's under this tire
I'm going to look for snakes and whoa do
you ever hear about the ladies about
that things a manor lady bought a house
older house and in the walls he kids
like here some fellas rats or something
to click the old old house it's good to
[ __ ] go through the walls find like
bricks from 1492 full gold bricks are
worth 30 million dollars well you know
the guy did we won't mention that the
guy at our table asked him about when he
found probably a million dollars worth
of silver in the walls of an old house
Ollie the producer he was helping us he
and what did he do he told the guy owned
the house I wouldn't have what they want
that guy kept it all for nothing it
sounded got you guys in because you
that's the time did you anything it
never did and I would have known that
and here it is now that's another
ethical quick now what'd he do there and
hold on he bought the house okay you're
doing work for him you find this stash
that belonged to a lady who had died she
died a long time ago
okay technically the guys about the
outsets his prop he didn't but he didn't
buy that silver that's bad silver
actually belongs to the estate or the
state you're going to have to say you
can you need there's a lot of laws
around there where you you're definitely
have to pay taxes or something oh yeah
you don't just get to keep that and
chances are this distant relative that
legally goes to and all that stuff we
didn't know it shows criminal on the
black market
well that's what I would have been is I
would have been like that's a million
dollars worth silver I'm being paid to
do work on your house okay now I found
that good that silver in your walls I
think personally I might just sneak that
silver or I'm going to just not share
and go hey do that bathroom so that
kinda it depends my relationship yeah if
the cat is cool and you don't think he
was he's a dick what I would eat test
them like a well it's time to play sober
yeah wow you found 50 lot 50,000 silver
exactly that's what I would have semi
honored that and then they did they told
they call the guy right away and I had a
guy either dying collagen collagen money
and so at the football Center the Dow
Ward center they pose like looking for
summer jobs extra money like let us know
let hands burg know so clop and I let
them know is it go this old man needs
help moving he's moving from this giant
house in this weird [ __ ] hobbit house
in the mountains of Boulder a guy will
help them and they go good money two men
20 dollars an hour for us like damn sick
we wake up 7 a.m. we get there the guy's
weird as [ __ ] eating hummus with his
fingers he's moving out of this big
house into this literally the top of the
mountain ain't nice finger down chief
like [ __ ] Shrek you move into this
little place up in the mountains it's
tiny it's in the mountain so weird it's
nice to like die up there so and it is
work we're working eight hours and he
goes if you guys don't break anything
I'll give you a bonus I know yours was
here for hours you guys work till expose
them give them on a bonus we'll take
care of you so we're getting the work
really need the money and we get done
and he does I'm you know what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna mail everyone's check man
or mail mail a check to everybody like
okay and just never in ever pay or she
never ever pay
coretablet depending on you like my
height I can tell you how to get this
out read I mean it was the weirdest
house ever seen just like see you guys
got your even scanned by somebody and
giving them the money anyway I was at
the airport I got out a guy with my
girl's car shooting out on my friend
yeah and you took my girl's car kept it
for three days supposed to wrap it we're
getting like this army green wrap matte
wrap on it and black rims kept it for
three or four days I keep texting but
odo limit take it well longer give him
whatever $3,500 they didn t just and do
the jobs just bid I know where he works
now I know where you live
yeah [ __ ] if you're watching
this nobody work nobody lives on the
site [ __ ] what do you do yeah I had a
guy guys better figure it out now $500 I
had more money sure I had a guy I'm at
the airport commodities in the suit and
he had his his bags on his push things
and he's like sir do you know where I
can I'm trying to fight him a bank
machine or something oh my oh boy anyway
gives me this long roundabout story
about how he loved it yeah Rob he's
trying to get to the thing and I was
like I'm gonna see you need man he goes
you know I mean I I mean right now I
would just take 20 bucks I mean I
whatever you can afford
obviously I need a hundred to get it and
I gotta go hundred seven no I do it I
wouldn't do it he's doing because I can
see that his bag he had you know you
know a bag let you hang suited it had
wire hangers and it was just David looks
like he was deflated there's nothing in
there it was a really helpful he had mom
around his lips and he was obviously
some kind of junkie but he was probably
50 or 48 and and I was just like any in
black thick black either you know lack
you probably used to be a handsome guy
back in the day now I went I'll tell you
what I'm gonna give you 60 bucks and he
goes and I will pay you back I need to
reference I go don't worry about it
doesn't matter if you buy it does matter
it does matter it matters to me here's
like a hard-on but this is my
good and I go you know what I'm gonna
give you 80 I just want to [ __ ] with
them he goes hey eighty bucks I'm gonna
pay you back sir I insist on your
getting a fake address I go yeah make
sure you give that back things I'm sure
you will and he kept going it does
matter it does your go thank you thank
you all I hear is I just walked away
lady [ __ ] off ya scared me till the
Sterling over for their guy was the ton
be a friend oh my god it was like good
bein out first
I love it's one of those matter now know
he know there's a guy's got he was
obviously he is to be military and he's
kind of really well-dressed handsome
tall white hair with a very with an
impeccable white waxed moustache
impeccable and oh yeah and he sits next
minute yes thank you very much
appreciate that thank you a little more
ice please thank you so much thank you I
appreciate that
mm-hmm and and it's going to read and he
looks over and I'm writing and he says
up you're on you're right
and I said well I'm trying to be right
here fantastic that's amazing
long story short he finally Hegel's
would love to bring some of your ready
she had talked on the phone
oh yeah of course you know me outside to
hold me why did you rattle you this what
should be the navy suit yeah yeah anyway
he wasn't an installer here is that
military have you've done something up
there and he was black but a lifelong
military guy who is retired and he said
I would love to read some of your stuff
and I said well you know I'm sailing he
said that I'm great
give me your address and and then
finally he kind of went dampener and he
said that busy and apply I said that and
I would love to grab coffee sometime
he shouldn't mangos you anything is that
you know I love to make the prints and
then I I go I go yeah yeah but I got a
warning I gotta warn you I go what's
that you guys so I make a friend it
makes a life and he says with him and I
went I've never done this
you don't be I'm pretty slick I went oh
well okay then I don't know there it is
it is I feel he has a big commitment on
battle each other and boy I went right
back to my computer and he just he
realized that he overstepped his
boundaries because I wasn't ready to
justify just a little over the bra
that's like trying to get down my pants
or I will try going anal on the first
night he for real I be judging on in
viola speech how do you know your bro oh
yeah exactly I said oh dude husband is
by the way I felt bad at the end of the
flight I kind of just went right back to
Matt Damon just come over and I don't
throw my way I'll send you my stuff
because you're Vegas I would like to
thank you I was like yo Rhiannon do you
guys Alec dial dip the toothpick and say
like a with little Tigers run around and
this other kid say my dad come because
say you sign of it sure is right with
academic Bob Lincoln I'm sure is long
story short we start talking and he goes
you know what man
[Music]
you know you don't want man what do you
play outside
oh where do I live close to hit you
don't like that done it pretty close to
here you know I walk doing this yeah me
too man I live right up the hill the
school man you're free then I expected I
knew it is gentlemen how old is the
doing at the Attic seven um
you were supposed to heroin yes sir you
look we should do something on Friday
you and I actually do some up brother
so that's super aggressive but you know
and he's like you know bit forty sure
you what you have seen and how I find
that you admire you a lot of friends for
here in need of I got a hit off a guy
that's what I'll do I'm crazy busy on
Friday night your jacket down man
then Saturday are you or better house
this way I do not and I just I don't
hurt his feelings in a nice guy said of
course I'm super busy you do I'm just
really busy I don't have a lot of time
do it your stuff you know me a kid you
got you get it Rob walk I give you we
just exchanged numbers I'm like I
learned just like yeah for sure I'll
Tiger it my bread off and then just put
them in the convict yeah also I'm
friends of me go what
hanging out good job Patti and Saturday
to Java love women
you trying to [ __ ] let's get a set of
kids for you your friend I have no time
yeah unless you have a blog as you get
suspicious well I'll ask them a terrible
childhood I can't do this
I look I'm all settling I can't do I
can't do this
John stay with the state great line you
want to be my friend I don't mean a new
friend of tools you want to be our
friend you going to order yet do you
want to changing a flag of places for
free then we can talk about other than
animal cells the unlock protocol that's
all school ends do those I could be
using front on Saturday though Hortense
I on Thursday night La Jolla you've been
to Louis let me take that loyalty Amy
think about it is the best place well
you gave me yeah I'm gonna find her a
vacation home [ __ ] I don't bro I got
five textured and the crowd I don't
think overstayed has become a it's a
classic you have I'm already clearing
state they're some of the best of all
time off center kind of are you at the
keys at condo I could smell no but
you're making my back on them you make
me mad okay because it's right on the
beach slap Comedy Store I'm doing so
let's play stuff let me tell you what's
like still that brings out that plate it
makes life easier
magical hey the comics talking about
income inserted to the comedy store is
magical it is the best place on earth
man and they said you know we love that
branch and you know I love I'll figure
out you know all forgot one get them up
there you know a lot of people asking
about you it was just a really good show
chin or semi came at a good time man and
then you know I went to this great
breakfast spot hey rose I got to make
sure I can get you into the concert of
oil if you're going to say a couple
things have you been there horse a
couple things all right
number one you [ __ ]
johnny-come-lately to the trends you
[ __ ] you I've been doing
standard for seven minutes
because I've been time it on my [ __ ]
phone I've been going to college during
a question since 2005 all right mm buddy
yeah - oh my gosh
so that's all have you been alive so
shut up you were born in 2006 or shut up
all again all right because you're an
infant now that's
good times or not you know let me say
that the condo loan it's amazing I have
to say that a little furious because
you've created your own touring band and
this [ __ ] podcast the big
groundbreaker like Nu yeah touring
business where yes you plan a sold-out
crowds and I've been doing this [ __ ]
since 2005 on the road slag it away not
stealing rooms on a Thursday and here
you [ __ ] come with five six texts hey
man the winds awesome
it's [ __ ] great yes yeah I know you
got it I don't a dozen time alone no I
got it over a dozen times I'll go so I
don't need you [ __ ] down unit boy is
great well it bothers me when you're
allowing out on the road with your
newfound touring business it's so
annoying that you're you're you're sorta
busty it seems they broke they're
busting at the scene was your top
student and I got to do local press to
build rooms I'll be the [ __ ] comedy
mix and Vancouver and not be a Denver
you sons of [ __ ] at the county and
[ __ ] please buy us tickets
hey I don't need you no no I got you I
don't need the wing I can do he gave me
a starting oh my god start swinging sir
McLaughlin please all working hard
appreciate and Denver and hometown
heroes I might take your body count shop
yeah yeah least I can do that yeah
anyway radio
thanks man well done is a fun time don't
talk to me about many places you go to
I've been there when we've shared some
new experiences together this way I
never bet the big theater yes [ __ ]
Chicago your 9:30 club sure having
special places no I haven't I paired up
with a fighter and my twin business glue
up son of a [ __ ] um I give you all
credit done well done this dark McCann
weird yeah
hey um can we tell so did you did you
find that fight to be Somali nothing job
so I throw my head me Joshua will show
us something who showed us these a real
chant hold on to our genuine with us at
time 3 years ago made two years ago the
unrolling a gentleman's choice and Emily
Josh was the neck I remember losing
these jobs or without this guys don't do
all it you could you shut the [ __ ] up
yeah the truth man he's the truth and he
heard a fight to get not about that
happens
no let's just start to me didn't how
about that entrance did you see a build
up oh my I've never seen interest like
when you can watch God hold up he walked
out they put him on raft they raised him
up his initials are red flames just
flames real real flames and he's
stand-in there just enjoying happening
Joshua
he's up there for five minutes off where
I'm like holy [ __ ] he better win this
looks ridiculous is amazing but I gotta
pressure your hometown yeah and then he
gets in there ninety thousand sold out
are you know you ninety thousand I got
even some people online loved it today
the judge is the biggest draw in boxing
right now be strong no can also ha -
Cowboys Stadium less than juleps twerps
they all they made available with 50,000
tickets to downstate and it open up the
hundreds it feeds a hundred dollar risky
they have all these 50,000 of the
tickets available
they didn't make a hundred thousand
available they only made fifty thousand
available he's not selling a hundred
thousand tickets you know maybe Mexico
hito I didn't make sure you'd sell
eighty ninety thousand hundred thousand
but besides back in two hours anti
Joshua England
Wembley demonstrate that's remarkable
well is it available time with people
because I'm Chavez Jr maybe in Mexico
and that would be a big job maybe yeah
maybe I don't I don't know could until
Chavez Jr you know it that's in Mexico
right into Mexico I think every Joshua
is dead by the way hose on the five
before right I know I had not seen
highlights I've never seen a people
lookin dude well he's easily
this isn't looking men right I mean that
me really is I mean just in every aspect
of how how incredible he looks and
crisco's no slouch either I mean they're
two like uber head level 42 yeah he's 42
lost a lot of weight if he thought speed
and footwork can be his kind of kid when
it was for a long time he's I gotta be
honest he'd be one of the best clip
shows I've ever seen I'm boy it sure
looked amazing footwork in and out and
we can have a really great
it's just anti Joshua's done monster but
gosh when I am down in the fifth round
and celebrate remember any time if it's
on it's over so you see them Dennis the
shop they're given now it's all over the
media
she's like this very Muhammad Ali like
we just put his arms up because just
down like that he thought you want let
me see the rest of the fifth the sixth
the seventh he looked [ __ ] deplete
explain that you screw what was that
rule meant for you just collect I go by
one click and all that like the nerves
that run all that goes it's over oh it's
like all the stress of it's over
yeah the focus that your blinders go
boom oh I was party time Wow your body
kind of relaxes and so you can see like
mentally keep kind of [ __ ] next and
say in the corner I can see what was
going on and they physically just
footwork came back to really starts
pressing them and then just get you know
there's not in had nine on tenth
I mean it was amazing and for Joshua
this is what you want if you're Joshua
fan you don't want him to go in there in
that fits around kids could go tease out
because then we don't know what Josh was
May done then you almost have a paper
champion way like I don't know a really
on takes a lot of guys is this a case of
clitoris being older it's definitely on
that clinch we've got knocked down came
back look better not anti Joshua
flatlined yes he pops up weathers the
storm in two rounds
yeah I was about to yeah three four five
star really picking back up three four
five minutes later and then you just see
that Joshua's he's a champion that you
want well that makes you guys because
you don't worry much you've ever been
past the seventh round advert right so
we didn't reverse and get knocked down
there seen face that bursting we've
never seen in face of world-class guy
fabric his competition has been [ __ ]
that's why Boston goes yeah so I was
hire them to use all the tools but men
you know what can happen when he came
back I'm like well there's the real
[ __ ] deal that's right there's the
real deal he's real but I was also
intrigued because critical was winning
most of those round at least point wise
it looked like he was hitting him more
how did you score it I scored I'd have
to go back as a real island gets not I
would say I so if the fight didn't get
so close let's let's work from that
relative that again so you got to give
this to 10-8 round yuzu - well okay but
for the most part no you went so to
score before the knocked out you'd only
be one today round
oh then that I got that I got I got
Klitschko winning by one round yes uh
the xfield most that were tied around
let's go by one right I had Joshua by
one round because you can't give
Klitschko attending around in the six
and not Joshua tonight's running v cos
he drops him Hall yes in the fifth not
ours that couch will drop to him but
either way it breeds I want to take your
shoes carefully to her up so then I have
Joshua Joshua by blond round but see I
saw Crisco Crisco won the sixth seventh
and eighth round I think just off points
right I'm other than I that I get Joshua
the base you of all the rounds leading
up to the fifth oh you did maybe I told
let's say light so maybe give them one
so you just put your oneself one two
three four four Joshua Raya and then
then you give them nine ten I saw Chris
code I felt that Jonah was peppering
Joshua in the beginning of the fight
like more in Hitman without all the ads
and just just good yeah uh your viewing
time strike doesn't always tell the tale
yeah I go back and wanted to crystal
lame I think puts go ended more like
jazz but empty Joshua percentage-wise
landed more power punches and that's
usually what wins the fight the power
punch @include start getting top three
best jabs of all time mmm a monster and
but you know they took it under contract
they find a to fight deal so they have
to fight again of course you'll want it
but I think Joshua can fight outside of
that belt you know that was for the
merge the belt though is for another
belt so you can fight the knee to fight
off your you could buy Deontay Wilder
you talk about
so there's reinstating flexor because
what I wanna see for the second fight
with Crisco
and Joshua is let's see if Klitschko
because he's so smart just sees your
fighter let's see what his game plan is
but he had a pretty amazing game plan in
mind game plays I don't know how you
improve on that I thought if you need to
let us right angle what he so reserve
those right hands yeah all right hand
landed under seen anyone eat a let's go
right in and we have seen the day yeah I
mean G&G flush not gush went down just
pops up but I think you can releases
more right hands and then John but John
them see I think in the rematch I've
died to see it's the best fight to make
right now yeah but I think Joshua is the
one who can make the most improvement I
think caliph shows like the benefit
amount of time so we know if this you
can do with the footwork and all that
more jazz and all that but Joshua he
wasn't sowing combos because she's known
as a combo puncher he's just looking for
the big shot which outfit ended up
working out for him but that's right and
either the guy who has more to go you
could see that Joshua 24 us yeah
strategically never have to seventh
round never been that mag to meet my
great if he has a lot of room for
improvement he's going to be great in
the rally great fight form to does
Wilder the sphere as he wants fight fury
much so here what to look in y'all be
Walter there's fury there's homeboy in
New Zealand all the people are going to
kill me that's in his [ __ ] name oh
god I forget side guys but he's a
monster
there's a lot of good huh give me give
me what do you think about fury suitors
of doublet Furies 400 pounds right now
he's made he considered mentally unfit
to fight you know we looked him up
general della he they were mentally
unfit to fight now he's getting back in
shape is shown he's literally 400 pounds
like you know even more I have so much
work to do perhaps how is he - Kate that
fights not have any time soon the thing
with furious is that I'm more scared of
that matches I am Klitschko for Joshua
because fury so unconventional it's you
can't get a rhythm or timing down he
makes it a boring fight the build-up
would be great but that's what I've got
inside a great fight - 200 how the bomb
if I'm Joshua guys I think you can beat
them it just Jerry makes everyone look
like [ __ ] because he's so weird and
awkward who knows that you're going to
show up remember - fights with Clinton
got cancelled one foot you'll fight one
inside Joseph Parker shot Joseph Parker
so you got Joseph Parker New Zealand
[ __ ] monster he's literally just your
stuff instead he got to Maori enemy if
you don't always look up as highlight so
Anthony Parker weak so we don't know
here most guys don't know man
Chakravarti yeah yeah just Parker most
of them don't know I'm here but out
outside of this he's a [ __ ] monster
it doesn't make sense for Joshua to find
my not because no knows who he is if
he's I do it all and think typically do
them yet [ __ ] monster not to do job
so for Joshua really it's a rematch this
ritual would be the biggest payday you
got to do that again which I think he
wins again but you know stuff like and
then fury and then
Deonte Walter just wants the less
big-name here but what about the answer
whether they didn't he it's the best
American heavyweight for sure which
what's that mean my best I'm saying so
what would it his skill level in
relation to Anthony Joshua says it's
similar
physically gifted and all that stuff
different Wilders you know he was a
basketball player he's tall he's lanky
he he doesn't use his jab very well he's
a right hand right the bronze bombers
right hand from [ __ ] Madden's and
that's it he doesn't throw a lot of
combo punches he really looks flat big
punch he me got out of
Klitschko fury Parker Wilders they just
match up there really wow it's a fun
fight but like Wilder you know he's not
selling out you know he would sell out
t-mobile Arena
he wouldn't you in sell before them no
and he did he hasn't faced a lot of come
to [ __ ] you know is recognizing 32 and
always on my dad hood pretty good some
great I've been rich great way and then
this weekend it's an elephant eating you
know great
but also just Boston generous this
weekend is Canelo Alvarez versus Travis
actually wait can't wait quite a man
I mean I mean freaking tank over on
schedule I love my tune back of it Oh
huge there yeah but there's so many
great matchup right yes sir yeah I can't
wait now know you reach to my home base
for my song like dog don't you don't do
what else is up buddy
um what else does not we think here oh
well I got a very extensive checkup do
you talk about this officer one more
time look if they try to frame it all
you talk about the doctor wanted by the
doc so I'm going to crew in cuffs and
send in like seven samples of my poo do
it like a test if I don't want to do it
it's just I don't feel like doing it and
you look awfully it's chocolate mousse
you say oh yeah you gotta yeah you [ __ ]
a train and you got to put in a test
tube
[ __ ] off into a thing the little I know
I don't I'm fine
I don't want to do all this crazy [ __ ] I
know what a [ __ ] this [ __ ] you know
who's coming in this week is Shark I
adult J shops are for the big
groundbreaking very happy about that we
you leave one Thursday Jake it's on
Wednesday
all right let's have dinner what a night
well I have a show Wednesday night let's
leave said forgot about that
we'll figure it out cancel your show
mother okay
not because it's sold out so now um you
trying to kiss you
I'm not kissing you dude I think I like
the other day what I think you smell
with any we should do the show and [ __ ]
each other anyway I'm not invalid me
near my stupid autocorrect and I
recommend doc I thought unless you're
into that sort of thing right you want
to dump it on your phone now it are you
right Ralphie I feel you guys you go
what was it
I it's just stupid when you entire boys
partying with that hot dog was it mailed
oh shut up yeah it's great
great so most beautiful women I've ever
seen in my life
his wife has a clothing company and she
is a lot of Brazilian models so we'll
she was a model
yes she's beautiful - she looked healthy
Krista maybe not her
but why this [ __ ] Deepa every cruise
with just white is fun beautiful yeah
beautiful kid do you want to go late get
weird we're talking about Todd's party
you want to go late get weird then I got
another text [ __ ] each other on the
beach I was like no man that's not my
scene I get a [ __ ] autocorrect just
joking
unless you're not then I'm cool with it
you know I think it's serious now I feel
safe I don't feel safe
dude I've been running the saying like
the stairs like a madman yeah I live
over there just a madman top if you're
single oh yeah I mean that's like what
in the world Cheney you're just up the
stairs it's good and where you stand you
get the guy doing a poet's - I saw one
guy wonder if you can I thought you sing
it don't dress like that just can they
sell that little lemon you don't have to
buy it yeah you do knives away I don't
have time to marry before his workout
dude if you come you have been to hell
in here
okay they ain't no bandana Lululemon
bins like the headband it does have long
hair don't make sense one here that's
why you were half president's different
that's why we have to have been yeah
matching yellow Lululemon top pants
shoes soft again wouldn't design okay
then took a look beard I'm body I was a
part of the guy had a source and he
tucked us up he talked to services a
time ago please I'm gonna go tell my
that's and untuck his tank top him and
talk to Louise a gay man there he's so
gay and under that there's flames
shooting out the spot well that makes a
division in a bad way just said that
there I go well you're allowed to in
that case if you're very flamboyant gay
I want you to dress my knee to candy
YouTube so I know what's going on that's
why don't make them your own you know
it's funny how you're allowed to do
certain things you're German if you're a
German
like you never know know that that would
be no no but if you're Michael Jordan
you can wear it their mustache somehow
you get away with that twice
somehow we're totally black majority
decided to have a Hitler no headings no
is because he's black I guess where I
would be like Michael listen if you can
tell that if I was not juggling the only
person is everyone that mustache the
only person I like you just so you know
like in list you do it you're the Air
Jordan you're gay you'll be great it's
all time there's only been one of a job
or that one other guy do wonder if
there's all that roadkill I don't know
mustache rides with a bit ler see you
from there sir now you need to clear it
up or you can leave this painting I hate
other words like right yeah that's my
only vice is doing you so is that the
only other world do anyone else does
that
what do you put you don't that's because
I can't get any job in the world that's
exactly a V like [ __ ] its level with the
Hitler I wonder if I like that I saw why
would you said do I wanna do is like you
know it no way am I going to see what no
way dude there's some girl in tight and
a thumb mama
I'm try am i working now John burn some
calories you have done it shovel you
work yeah she's on the stairs in this
they're like a couple one two what bit
corny you come I tease my honeydew's
in grace management IDEs nothing yeah
blacks on which every step she stepping
up and then she's she's doing this she's
stepping up and going
I asked yeah she's looked at my who then
she's an ass expert yeah so I started
doing it okay I'm real sword
you know Glenn right I started when I
get the thought sir yeah like her yeah
and that's just really lame we have to
tapas I said something like no wonder
because in my head I was thinking no
wonder she has an ass like I think
that's a can I bring the guys my
prototype slick there is not hot out
choose you Dallas
no wonder traffic and I just ran off the
Illinois direction like I'm in fifth
grade ah good no wonder be knowing how
the conversation
yeah woman she has a great ass she's
doing that all the time
yeah and then you're just talking your
head and then she sits on it no wonder I
could have done that with my son when
I'm at a male conversation and I get so
wrapped up in my in a conversation of my
own head there you can I see and I go
yeah you guys are [ __ ] [ __ ]
and my son goes who's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
hold on hold I did it now they're
muffler myself don't say a word - well
we have a couple fish you remember the
convention I do about nothing zero dark
thirty five indicated zeros are 30 are
zero dark thirty hotter and the kid
we're in the dark I'm gonna do the big
round breakdown with it I suspect you in
the dock nice one beat so no don't
fondle each other or do before you start
the show
don't [ __ ] each other there it's a grope
free environment unless it ain't mmm and
we drowned break down [ __ ] suck in the
dark no what can you not be that
aggressive can we just say groping like
that's so [ __ ]
especially the way you you pop your cage
much Thaksin i doing where I'm gonna get
a nice [ __ ] a cowboy slap to the face
and a dicksuck is Oklahoma wonder
whether we're there mate onea I think
casino yeah igniting of fina Calista
casino means my help good food there
great coffee house no bad coffeehouse
we've been we've been all over America
yeah Oklahoma art assault border it's
very strange what if used two years
Oates [ __ ] mouth say everything money
coming around that coffee house so we're
going to call this and where is he a
snapping turtle yet you think he's there
I guarantee there I wonder how you
picture that I'm gonna bite your foot
no are you out of your mind that would
reduce you like me our boy was do do we
have on highly Houston type ear salad
now ecology so well that I would imagine
are now an alligator on a cacophonous
older one take a toe socks now let's old
one you together because it's so in
Oklahoma there's a guide sit around and
the all the kids on it means a giant
Reuters Hank
bringing four-cylinder and the features
pisses on them yes sweets there yeah old
[ __ ] bride riders it's I might
[ __ ] stranger danger moving on see it
I mean every go to her like very cool
woody in third grade
he'd been into a phone book and I held
onto it or me was People magazine either
way it's a good time
that guy'll be there he looks exactly
like his turtle that does not have to
lay from from diabetes from war eating
tonight Cheryl yeah or or the amount of
Sun his pink skin has taken in he's
looked like your hot dog wins over
cooking labors yeah cuz skin is all gone
breakup death he's got barnacles even if
you look like [ __ ] you done and don't
write up barnacles
turtle even its turtles like it used to
moisturizer on your skin this turtle
doctor well you though mister opens
house might be gotta hydrate that
[ __ ] go first on the [ __ ] being a
lodged in the water the water you're
holding in the Sun he was yells all's I
expect to sing our national Oklahoma his
mouth in there but it's not as open
Delta I can
okay we're I'm so dry I think appeared
stunned Ryan turtle and then the guy
looks like a turtle who's going to die
first
that's that turtle 300 years old yeah
some people on let them their physical
body good Oklahoma Houston you not they
tell their how do you want that now if
you want you want butter with that fried
bread well how about that food do my
brandy have to fry the bread yeah the
most healthiest thing at that fair was a
bus giant turkey leg and I felt a smoked
smoked
blacker than night smoked I was like
that's a black turkey leg mouse well
maternal blood circulates will happen
now leaving you people what's wrong with
the smoked black Turk you are somebody
bleeding
what's wrong with black turkey legs
nothing there I think this goes way too
cute nurse you know whites with you I
like dark meat I chose red turkey wild
turkey and the legs are blood red when
you when you pluck a turkey in the field
this hunter talks are everybody when you
pluck a Tom like this when you pluck a
Tom in the field that Tom's got its legs
are not like me it's it's dark dark like
brown and that meat tastes just like
Turkey and I mean less what rather
was not boy loves a lot less so much
goes broke to time our campaigns in this
campaign they were talking about gently
just to do you shouldn't gun I'll shine
like fitting with you know he's like oh
hi Neil blessed from Georgie so you got
is what I saw man at first time or
mailing as far as actors concerned
easily tough tough guy
[ __ ] yeah bottle the product is just
you've got their data right kidney taken
be wrong if you go kid yeah so we're
tying here's dude we should go shoot
gods of it it will I have a bunch guys
we know the reins of pride
uh-huh here's a little waiting you got
it let's just let's make merry now let's
go Sunday night and Sandy descent hate
Heights go Senate Sunday night at
midnight every Sunday
it was Wyatt see there I still want to
go I don't know what to say them I'll do
it with him I miss I miss on midnight
Sunday night that's how you mix it up
walk on it awesome the only time we can
go yeah Wayne Cox hundred he sparred
last time he sparked he not the stood up
he hurt a couple guys he lives hit me
young heels hard loves mouthpiece over
more than I did
what do you spell and you stepped on
he's tough
that's a good we head to town stop it
needs to hit tourists too strong about
dropping dude we need you on the show
you some good yeah let's get him on the
show I love ya I love the guy I'm um not
like maybe when I use you relax
not only does tell me to relax we gotcha
alright the first one is the fire
festival yeah what the [ __ ] inaudible
ja Rule and some other guy that has
money they were going to promote this
huge festival the Bahamas a music
festival and I was supposed to have
blink-182
egos and some other group Jam I'm on
board over the kendall Jenner promoter
did so did Bella ID'd a bunch of
different stuff let's have like famous
just catering and all stuff and it just
turned into like the worst thing ever
what people can get the island [ __ ] that
was stolen before which nuts up stuff so
people couldn't even get there people
that were there couldn't get off all the
climbers
Tencent's are the glamorous like
accommodations turn out to be like way
to go like relief tents
yes doctor really antenna yeah and they
were serving bread and cheese instead of
gourmet meal
magis that happened so they had to
cancel the event and now the attorney
Mark Geragos he's suing on behalf of the
you know those people for a hundred
million dollars because they feel that
those guys are lying
who does anybody go to like there's a
class-action suit so the people that are
complaining about that whole thing
that's the same might have do that
they're all they want a hundred million
both hot Wow
well you're terrible idea and then
kendall Jenner getting a bunch of that
glass steel on on so city yeah but I
always said I chose to run you got to be
careful when you promote but right what
details does she know about them so
what's wrong with your name so one plan
was like yo can you please blast out to
your 32 Gillian followers if you'd be
such fun time dude and that's not
involved in that something's going down
where somehow I know the details I'm not
taking any part of anything well we run
it as you like that one is from all time
because also you runs promoting
providing local charities is hard
because this podcast has such a wide
reach that you have to be careful what
you use the airtime for it's just you
have this problem people know better
with me you know better what do you do
with other local [ __ ] what he's talking
about yeah there's better ways to go
about it and you're not doing your work
to be lazy your resets me cuz you did
work we do it yeah I know better
they still want to stretch us friends
again the will promotion I don't know
Ben yeah another stretching techniques
I'm not put my name on that who is that
villain you remember stretching
techniques I was going to promote yeah I
can will promote it to other you know I
thought yeah and I wasn't about that I
wouldn't do that talking about on my
insults million per free session mmm-hmm
but right who was good the type than it
was good it was really good but it's
also Scott of course yeah I lied so he
blasts out of people like your mind full
of [ __ ] yeah that's right that's what
environment and that's where I was I
don't know I had to try it out for
myself I'm not gonna do any I haven't
tried out make sure it's good you know
these times of stress on oh my god I've
never seen it done that way you know any
time just doing like 30 years of Tears
yeah not what so insured or and new
stretch what are you never stretch that
muscle over full
yeah well I mean you know you were
pretty like I remember I'm proud of them
and I'm just going to say this out loud
cryotherapy I've also done ice baths and
if you look at the majority of people
that have done sports like high-level
sports football players especially you
know and they're certainly like
tried-and-true methods over the years
that work one is ice and the others
anti-inflammatories and all pro athletes
will tell you that because they have to
answer their money the money depends on
that's I don't believe that cryotherapy
does what ice baths all smoking install
smoke and mirrors right don't give a
[ __ ] what it tells you what studies they
find nothing replaces in the ice pack
right now they're beat you know why it's
big just new and it's not because people
can belong so - yeah but also doesn't
hurt I start sucking it yeah they
[ __ ] suck but they've worked that
cryogenic chamber oh you want to eat
whatever you can for that you know can't
get to one another freezer sit there for
ten minutes
close it Monday on your body feel yeah
is that me allure just it doesn't get
down into the must now it doesn't burn
your skin if you're Frost by the city to
do that that's right now it's go I went
in there was very cold but it was it
slowly told for the two minute yeah and
it's not nice but now it's just nice the
three mention it now ice bath for 15
minutes different animal its gift now
there's a reason why the NFL NBA us
everyone pro athletes where their money
depends on bringing their information go
to LeBron James Instagram if you if
you're curious lives LeBron James
Instagram
let me know steaming a cryo chamber or
ice bath that's athlete on the planet
yeah has more than one gun you're
thinking by Kashia he could sleep in a
crowd chamber right back and an anti
inflammatories really nice you've got to
go from an executor yeah it's an easy
way out though because I found fix work
you have to buy ice get soap your
bathtub or whatever the time it's
[ __ ] freezing or field in her your
hands are going to hurt its mentally
it's a beast
alrighty nose Oh My look at that soccer
mom Stella cryo chamber for two minutes
girl you recovered sure of
now for athletes man it's all [ __ ]
if so smoke and mirrors there honey
dicks need eyes there's a lot of stuff
like that
there's a lot of stuff like that go to a
few if you want go to [ __ ] yogurt
landing go to the back where the
refrigerator is thats walk in there and
that's a crowd chamber it does nothing
what do we get for old people that have
like nagging injuries and stuff oh no no
I mean you know what it's better than
gonna dick in the face
does that help you change I'm sure
anything has I'm holding the old
cucumber tempted to the face would be
better as a man to be really hearing
something for three minutes it's super
cold I'm sure you could make the
argument that there are certain things
that happen the body that could be
beneficial to here how would I like this
argument I bet if you went into a freeze
let's say wheel is restaurants up big me
freezers to win there for three minutes
we're going to crowd chamber I bet you
that that freezer was do more free or
they're the exact same that's fair I
mean people throw me studies it'll check
this down we learn this I get all that
I'm telling you man nothing plays like
that it's all honey [ __ ] yeah - how
cool would it be if you went to a place
widely for me it when I wasn't happy oh
my god I love this thing you beyond the
facility where it's just ice baths and
hot tubs and you can go ice baths for
two minutes hot tub per minute ice bath
do you want to get better that's what
you do colleges happen yes you don't
have crowd yes cryogenic [ __ ] yes
serve those because we know it works
because you know it works and that
there's also not sexy though that's
upset now who's going to sign up lineage
but L didn't knew what sells is a new
way to do something that's fast
I knew it Nitro group I don't let you
mean [ __ ] cult all right right you
nice talking right that's right but but
did all these things are gimmicks up out
of like you know extract the caffeine
better more caffeine whose ID actual
tastes the bead and we have these tools
like all the way like this and it's a
cold brew that takes all night I
understand I'm sure it's good insurance
got its own qualities but I'll have an
iced coffee all this is the other thing
you know Starbucks is doing these
goddamn dragons frappuccinos unicorn
frappuccinos you see this [ __ ] I'm
good
no why don't know I'm a sugar guys I bet
I'd love it
[ __ ] that though I was at Starbucks the
other day yeah so in front of me or one
of those dragon prep chinos this [ __ ]
they probably took I don't know 10
minutes to make realize what a goddamn
black coffee that's why I made that post
yeah [ __ ] you two months all the tools
who want the dragon and [ __ ] you're
going on you're in this life you go to
begin the comments on it should be
[ __ ] flashing light on glitter and
bubbles everyone who wants get [ __ ] done
in this line it's just black cop yeah
all you communists can go over there and
then have my American black coffee like
a magic God worked it we're going to
work enough time for that that's like
the Sebastian Sebastian that the
comedian the great comedians mathematics
telecourse
he's just joke about that he'd be like
you know the flat please with little
load of stone with whipped cream please
Thanks can I get a half a half-caff half
decaf latte and he's like you get a
black coffee and you could if you feel
bad
dude I always in a rush to and she's
like oh my god I would love to try one
of those what is this is the unicorn or
is it the dragon fly like dragon [ __ ]
it's the dragon fabric you know the
goddamn dragon it's little Jade into a -
Oh a stroke each special no your own
mother una I'm my brother it slowly as
you ask for the green dragon no he's
more in a fashion that he makes you look
like me he's more than the faster dude
he like he's got every one of his shoes
he's got the bag he likes the newest of
everything he likes his coffee to be so
salaries like anything new and trendy I
gotta have a talk with him just on the
trendy trendy some trendy trendy but
yeah he wants and also it's not on the
boards I don't think so it's like code
word I'll take the Green Monster that's
how they do it they're not it's like
code word yeah welcome to the right it's
all the same [ __ ] different diet so I'll
take the dragon why would you be it so
like I'll take the pink much like the
[ __ ] tighten up
I'll take the winter manual what about
[ __ ] it
are you in for drugs I'm running out of
your drugs are not just a dragon to the
wrong Starbucks you get mad they do a
lot of research on that they must do
some test groups on that they think I
roll out something that big it's just a
temporary thing or it's just going to be
temporary for kids you know what
frappuccinos are a drag in all this you
don't they all right okay coach shakes
nose a milkshake yeah it's Starbucks Mel
hearings yo you just do not judge them
ya know their milkshakes yes separate
line and even do it separate store call
it Starbucks dragon and have it purple
and Piero called Starbucks for die-hard
start with coffee
Jarvis kids call it Bill the [ __ ] call
it fun of God not starvin you little
bear I like build a [ __ ] and you guys go
in there and you're you [ __ ] dragon
share you and also why does got these
white brain dragons it's one's gotta be
a dragon shaked called the [ __ ] tea
top shades cuz it looks like a peacocks
tail you seen these things now we should
get one I have a matter only lined
alright what else is that
boss we got wow we were too went off
cannot this darkness in the elevator I
know stories from my dick again
Slenderman
start the next one is Paige Vanzant
she released her own sort of self self
promo for Reebok which it lasted piss
she's nearly flash it didn't but she was
trying to like the way you looked at me
she looked like she was overly trying to
be sexual without trying to be sexual oh
she was here she was like lift her shirt
up and show her bra and then her Reebok
like whatever you decide to commercial
is a post by her she hosted it and when
she liked revived she was like and look
here but should we do it very very
sexually man I wish we had the video
that you could actually look on your
phones later but I'm sort of a sub you
know just my place down but I thought it
would be yet so good and og and it all
you mean your tax value
um she sends me texts yeah I know she uh
you know rewatching she's on the premium
starting Reba
so Reeboks like yo girl we ourselves
some [ __ ] kids you need to
flash some ass and kids that's where
that comes from
well she did that and then she had a you
know a bunch of backlash of course some
of the UFC fighters you know we're
making fun of her sweet - P fighters
Angela Hill was one of them I think I'm
not ESD fired Ben Askren there is there
a comparing her to those 20 hundred
numbers you know this girl's call for a
good night with an ass her comparator to
that and if she deleted all of those
posts she blocked him delete them
I don't you block him but she did we'd
all look at it uh-uh I think you're
gonna get backlash to this the pain she
she's a good fighter is she a premium
sponsor dream on fighters no but she
that's what the market value is repaid
benefit that's what she is
that's a her fault it's not seeing
Punk's colleges huge draw it's not you
know all the saints worked up is huge
drawl they have the town to back it up
absolutely [ __ ] not this is what the
UFC's built they built these you know
these action heroes that will see great
in life but these action figures can't
do the moves that the GI Joes can they
look [ __ ] great the GI Joes will beat
the [ __ ] out of them and they're making
less money some extent yeah so for Paige
the reason why they're hating Angele
Angele no I love it
Cheryl the greatest ice ever in Japan's
whatever not in your sea however is a
hill Washington right now with Charles
giving out any was not one person shows
are you doubting your sea fighter that's
not one person
Paige watch there's such this [ __ ] down
yeah so that's where the hate comes with
Ben Askren I love been achieved when you
see [ __ ] be world champion hit rest
everybody but he's a wrestler so they're
never gonna sign them all so what's he
been doing of course you know that's
what she'd say she knows that though you
got to check it out though see this
works on let me see it sexy like
sometimes I go to great memory so it's
not the women you'll see file in the
semi sexy it's like Caitlyn Jenner style
is it you're a Taylor genocide be sexy
for services contractual tada
damn yeah you double your capsule she
slept in our contractors she's forced to
make certain videos social media post
you know and I'll see what is she get it
what else you gonna sell that Hey you
just see you like three box I like
working out too nothing better than this
I'm hurt I would have went ten full you
wanna make some news you put that
[ __ ] Reebok song on you flat watching
for difficult position is she's turning
large if you think it's not next part
you pull it over play no no no no cousin
I go see possible they'll pull that ad
you can't last that long you far
rebodied are you going as you go
it still doesn't smell Reebok rebus
still suck Bridget sexy products like
this Reebok hmm oops
still doesn't smell Reebok hmm that was
a burner rebuff dot-com /page form a set
up Reebok Reebok her I don't do well
with beans
here's one Reebok
ooh that was wet race [ __ ] my pants yeah
watch Wow your eyes that time do one for
your mother judge damn and I should like
now Reebok oops this is the wrong day to
run a toilet paper
good thing I got an old t-shirt Islan
Reebok yeah I had a turtle head sticking
out now good thing up a shitty Reebok
fight kid on the garage and wipe my ass
with this is this is it gray bar huh
don't worry that was a queen did I go
too far
tell me your shattered um hey I paid you
to do it I'll make the fart noise I
didn't mean to like throw up spit and
then I'll fart I didn't mean to
really okay Reebok sorry I have trouble
with my court
well if making a silk shirt are you
doing though I tried I'm doing Luke and
then you'd already Reebok oh I better go
white I know you can't wait to find one
for me buddy
this is Reebok here Oh save what Oh what
do you say that I'm soon Birds now watch
I saw them do you know ready this is
going to make it like make a really
tasty
tasteful for them right Reebok smells
like clams right here's one I got I
thought here's the campaign here we buy
kid already
Reebok Rob Jesus Christ sounds like [ __ ]
well let's come on the neck I know
that's what I thought they were looking
for though no um what else
comp on what what else you trying to be
sexy so really should be like this ready
Reebok come on time damn it
that's [ __ ] Haley buck yeah that's how
it would work Darrell yeah
we'll excuse me that's what you say
that's really on Isis I have gas scuse
me huh
oops I said it
oh I know Reebok brought tell us even
he's excited who see her [ __ ] is Matt
I would be he alright oh no here we go
ready Reebok
Shinda naina last night well good that
sound like a donkey first nothing like a
foghorn
hey Paul as a father hello applause hold
Alfred and I'm appalled
you're bad with too much yeah that was
just too much this is where I draw the
line
you know I'm sweatin this yet chin
I think she's forced to do that she sex
appeal is her biggest attribute so she's
using that they're paying her bills yell
did she she had to show middle Sheila's
usually good all right for sure you're
backing for there's a play that was one
star go ahead [ __ ] from Moscow to
Thailand to Bangkok and it hit bad
turbulence 27 people were injured when
we made these spines were broken Oh plop
and the injuries were a flood gashes on
the head gashes on guess overhead
bleeding everywhere broken arms broken
legs and it 110 seconds of turbulence
holy [ __ ] - don't have the seatbelt
I'm sure the ones that got damaged big
time probably didn't have the satellite
mercy bomb and a baby's head their
spines bro the usual sit the reports are
three different babies have their spines
broken this big guy right there there no
II just feel like I've maybe a fracture
yeah it could be a factor so it could be
okay as long as like how do you break
legs and arms in turbulence cuz you go
dude they said there's blood on the
ceiling
oh so you move the claims if they go
back up I saw a guy in the Academy's
posted a video and people are literally
like what and then there's just peanuts
oh no that's crazy [ __ ]
Oh
and then hear the guy yelling ah we're
going to be a little delayed yeah it's a
front upside out that I spiked
turbulence give me gas I'm so sorry
Hollis brother fart when I'm nervous I'm
nervous as [ __ ] please don't sue they're
like wrong
thanks for flying power past their
airline yeah my simple story I've been
with my wife when I I've been with
guests what we don't know that well and
I just got it twice her she's so
embarrassed by stuff like that a little
well [ __ ] I just go after but nights
going by and I'm like you know I know
the mono so I just go so I'm going to
say something on my said wife said
something and it's like and yeah and
then I did the horses are great because
they really read like the environment
eyes go brother do does if I'm eyes and
she's because she was oh she doesn't
know what to do so your children because
they need to learn and she needs to our
not to talk about [ __ ] doors if it
here in route remember beware at scopa
evening looks as though use like I'll
have the author's quintic alibi using
black calamari
we're there with you know some ladies a
group of friends ramen wine and also
some criminals oh my god
you're what oh my god wills like to
resolve God well well well not you he
went on for an ally because we get about
an hour like will you know really
concept of woman okay nice conversation
nice Lionel I wanna oh hi girls like oh
my god we're gonna go ice is the owner I
goes yeah you gotta throw your bathroom
the way down the wall Padilla was like
peeling up the sides the mare was
shaking well you know she got Jim
[ __ ] at Thailand airline I'll try to
show you this up here excuse go yeah
then I'm Andy a hot chick from Miami's
21 years old and she would meet up guys
at clothes and then get them to take her
back to their place
yeah and then she what you know dude get
massages and stuff like that and drink
with them and end up slipping them drugs
and they're robbing them Rolex watches
like thousands of dollars of the cash
sir she's not as multiple times every
way Natalie so how that Natalie know so
how about number salad this so my buddy
advantage right there you can't still
put so dare you get caught for time one
up to the source Young's make up one of
the guys saw her the next day or
something at a club with share my
tattoos on her hands that made her
noticeable can recognize little so then
he called the phone and now let me ask
you this she take him home suck them off
your own no suck and just massages yeah
it's used she's smart damn so she wasn't
I let's lay down for massage have been
there out Dan I'm impressed lipid into
the gym yeah so so my buddy
Sixers girl same thing it's like why
this girl really hot so over I'm just
like whatever and he's buying drinks and
stuff and and she he goes dude this girl
is down so he takes her to she takes him
to his car and he pulls his pants down
and gives him the old sucker ooh
let him it goes right in the car and he
close pants all the way down his neck Oh
skills up all the way down all I was
like a room and then he's like wall
amazing she goes have a great night
he's like [ __ ] and see ya whoa goes back
to a friend let's take the spa together
where's my [ __ ] wallet haha this guy
yeah you know what billion she's a
better woman than this but you ladies do
so you just there's nothing just
stealing a [ __ ] no suck you suck you
suck you suck
I got one for my buddy older gentleman
about 50 something now he's in the
closet out in Las Vegas I'm not there
all my boys my brothers there Jaden
knows this story my buddy's older dude
he's like dude this girl that's all this
girl is all over him and just that I
must depend upon it just a dime piece
like all over the Indies 57 cuz I do she
liked you know he's like she liked that
and she likes daddy
and he goes you stated and then my buddy
goes can I see your ID and she's like
Wyatt is a kid carry each docetic which
didn't you
this isn't he right this thing is you I
know I'm under 21 I sneaked into the
clubs Oh
anybody drink since you want to look
over in the other table please
how do you think that girl was I'm so
afraid 16 years old 14
oh god no 14 oh boy
oh oh oh prank
yeah were they ready to bring it 48 in
Brie's [ __ ] time all not fell under
they this is my by Charlotte you just
now will go to jail which is reciting
[ __ ] Barney did that without a red
flag or D my god trial ecology so the 21
I tried Alvin comes in with 21 year old
the other Delmon 40-foot where this is
different way they're guys I've been
surprised of guys on the mat 14 not only
did [ __ ] you record give Pete a stinky
ass off the bat 14 exciting my friends
kinetics man yeah my buddy will strike
up your older a become your spot on your
[ __ ] he though I'm not hating no he
didn't do anything goes how are you in
she was my sister you know she bring the
clutter all the time this but I don't
care about he goes 14 goes oh my god
ways you go I'd wonder what he does you
have to get I would matter what you need
to get the [ __ ] out of it and chooses
like you can't be around I'll be like
you can't be around and yet it's not 14
I'm Christ she's not any am I'm home 17
yeah that's crazy
bad back hot [ __ ] is listener agency
wants to even do that like 14 hogs want
to go she reports young man 600 I got
those random 14 dragnet new show empties
14 pregnant man oh man that's Mitch here
oh yeah he told beer dad yeah well out
there guys go there a lot of guys that
just don't ask any questions and then
just you know like it's like going to
strip club Garrett how many times this
is my place
stalking this girl all night and
and he goes just a nice girl man oh yeah
I what was that because I saw him give
her money as he left I know was Atticus
you know the game of money match and I
go how much did you Gary I gave him some
money bro
and I go well Twitter she isn't
listening because she's she's first of
all she got come simulator now I got
professional I own I go what do you mean
you I had to pay her the rest of her
shift she said come see me later also
she's lagging a star be a nurse she says
go girl go how much did you give her
English so well good can't hear her I
think the 1700 bucks and I go and either
had it was like he was born
oh and I go I go [ __ ] if that money
is gone she's not gonna see you later
she's not gonna see you later
so soon and it was Janata ball yeah when
she thought she gon work together or
right yeah right she knows you're a nice
girl do I just feel like well you know
she's a mercenary commercial production
now you know what your bounds done
Mentalist yet you alright you
entertainment or and they both will
default okay
so Jimmy Manoa you know the remember was
that he was posted well he asked for a
fight with David Haye in boxing yes and
then he would hate no David Haines
wanted to fight was Jimmy called not to
I think on one of the sides I think it
started out with David Haye right
he thought started either when he said
that he met up with David Haye or spoke
to David he met up with Dana White and
then Dana White is interested in this
fight he said he likes the numbers and
he would like to get it done so in case
it's going to happen
come on no did anything necessarily on
that Connor card but there's just saying
bad here gonna do it period it's just a
[ __ ] show like I think Connor Mayweather
Connors like this unicorn and that fight
makes sense you know like 10 or so on
Orthodox and Mayweather it's older and
it's just negative five and we've a
response in that kind of cool if you do
it once now you start doing this it's
kinda like if they're so strapped for
stars and cash and it's that's what a
surprise
right into what it looks like you're
just so desperate spectacle the
interview it just makes a mockery of the
sport I know I'm being condescending
that I've been the the biggest advocate
for Conor Floyd one and done
I don't even rematches I don't see Roy
Jones sencilla I don't see Nate Diaz
versus Andre Ward I don't need that
[ __ ] can I live with it - this is a
thing Kimmy MELAS is a traditional
striker he can sit down box with David
Hayes and get [ __ ] school some it's a
sport look terrible
does he not know it's not to have
artists there he's old stores with
Keeley's just lost a fight I watched a
moment chenko and TJ Dillashaw spar on
YouTube
and you know it was amazing to see just
how good in boxing moment ago it's
compared to working more unorthodox and
best strikers in the UFC and by TK's own
admission it was like it was going to
school was like going to school which is
different sport you know IG Jerry would
never fight alone with Gingka no
president but no no I wouldn't be pretty
but the thing about global change I'll
make some difference he doesn't move
like a body moves like a boy athlete
shoes like a almost like MMA boxer a
hybrid yeah he's not your traditional
basa
yeah jumping jumping to the side doing
crazy [ __ ] yeah you like man neither
that's just a bummer
well see you soon all right the biggest
guy in Hollywood I'm sure you know Ryan
Seacrest is far the busiest guy ever if
you just took on the co-host role of the
Kelly Ripa live show you know how she
had babies string height monster hunting
for yeah he left yeah so now Ryan
Seacrest is going to be the co a
full-time cold I'm cold damn well I'm
not going to also not to American Idol
darlin
there's rumors of bring it back and they
offered Tanya the position oh [ __ ] we
got live we got live
we got night we got
it has sort of rumors they offered
tonging a godly amount of money to bring
it back and that's the rumor
bottle I'm sure seat Crescent hosts that
I'm sure you can do this season with
Kelly Ripa I'll do some weird beef to
inherent Strahan yeah yeah sue but what
he wanted to leave to go to Good Morning
America he didn't tell her like until
really late
see I heard they had pieced the entire
time I don't know no I'm sure to get
info but I heard they're deep inside
time Mike stop [ __ ] out man but his
goal was always do good morning good
morning merica
oh and they tried like a million
different guys with Kelly Ripa like they
did a bunch of guest those I do not
define well she's so good man so funny
she's good and their advice yes I mean
for rating so sure I just feel like I
don't know you know Ryan Seacrest
working sober I let crowded yet the
daily show I used to watch it today
Amazon there that time but I'll tell you
like a daily my previous radio yeah
doing all these different things they
say he's a madman you know he also was
he's behind the Kardashians with the
ease with everything cameo sir oh yeah
nice about to Mike
I could never do it delicious man that's
it along the wall I'll just give you a
smaller Billy Ray Cyrus he changed his
name to Cyrus just Cyrus just Cyrus and
he's coming up with two different
versions of Achy Breaky Heart
EDM and Spanglish hey bro any man that
ship sailed yeah hey bro is rebranding
but remember remember with vanilla ice
trike come out with heavy metal ice ice
baby yeah yep it's gone man let it go
let this ship sail let it sail I'll try
to jam into them now they butter that's
it all right all right all right all
right
your job knowledge well peak a real
quick hobby became sorry he don't stop
invited the President of the Philippines
rubber Eagle dwarf day a bad man yeah I
don't know if you guys know but you know
he said when he was inaugurated is he
and he was actually one of the first
things he said Moses he if you are a
drug addict or sell drugs I will kill
you
and then he said there are three million
drug addicts in Hitler killed three
million Jews were killed over that six
million this editor killed three million
Jews we have three million addicts in
Philippines and I would gladly slaughter
them all that's the president's a bad
bad yeah 91% of approval rating he's a
man he stands up the remember couple
things going to fill Katie I don't know
if you guys know this but it was a
Spanish colony for three hundred and
some-odd years and it was an American
colony from 1898 to 1946 so the
Philippine the idea of being you know
Filipinos have the strong sense of
Independence they were subjugated under
colonial rule for a long time both
Spanish and American so you have to
understand that they have when a man
like Duarte says you know Barack Obama
can go to hell he's a son of a [ __ ]
you know they like that because he's
saying [ __ ] you to the colonial powers
having said all that people should know
that these extrajudicial killings and
I'm saying this because there's a
tendency for populations to try to solve
problems this way kill all the criminals
kill all the drug eyes kill all the drug
dealers we had something called due
process because it makes our country
actually stronger and when you have a
president who says that the military and
the police can kill people without a
trial without evidence but just on
suspicion or on their own visual
evidence and shoot them which they are
doing to the tune of over 6,000 the
problem with that is guess what happens
all the sudden vigilante groups start to
exit they know they can get away with it
and then what happens is vigilante
groups start start selling their killing
skills to people so all of a sudden
people go you know what oh I have beef
with that guy over there
and you get caught just tell him that he
was selling drugs better yet plant clubs
on and all of a sudden you have roving
gangs of vigilantes who are loyal to the
strongman and all on order and
institutions breaks down and that is
called the antithesis to democracy and
it's also a closet of the purge that's
right so just keep in mind that whatever
you have a strong man who thinks he's
above the law which Duarte does and
there are other people like Putin who
does some are saying you will pay a very
dear price you will you may think that
they go after the bad guys but it's a
matter of time before they come to you
because no one is controlling those
people and I want to add one more caveat
human rights workers in the Philippines
are all kind of up in arms about this
and documenting this stuff and Duarte
said human rights workers are getting in
the way of justice and the implication
there is if they are part if they're
getting in the way of justice they are
part of the problem so guess what maybe
they need to die too and believe me it's
a matter of time before vigilante groups
the police the military start killing
civil rights and human rights groups and
you know why that's not surprising
because it happens [ __ ] over and over
again in countries that don't respect
due process and the rule of law be
commenced without the knowledge in place
will fact that blasts without I don't
know these researchers but I'm pretty
sure they believe in flatterers too as
well researchers found that people
express who express their preference for
bitter taste such as black coffee are
more likely enjoying manipulating and
hurting others it's interesting I can't
be true based off your taste buds so I
got like bitter things like you can't
make a strong enough tea like green tea
can't be trying to coffee can't be
strong yes sir I like anything real real
women if you have a hood when it was
dark you grabbed at me interrupt me put
some [ __ ] right yes folks I don't
know I'm going to need these these you
have to be careful with studies and
research like that haha
has it been peer reviewed that's what
studies there always have to be peer
reviewed right you remember that was
always nobody comes over the study you
have to replicated I think in when it
comes to medicine you do it in three
different journals three different kind
of different independent lines of
inquiry that come to a consensus there's
all kinds of checks in
balances for that anytime a researcher
comes in and says hey you know this is
this does this that has to be checked
super skeptical science but science is
all about being skeptical it's all about
being like I don't know you're gonna
prove a messed up people drink coffee
live longer I know about science it's
true story probably but not black if we
can't add a like cream and sugar
knowledge go bye-bye that's what the
accident some coffees get me but without
all the [ __ ] to your screw I think I
say my friend my friend Peter cast zero
dark thirty like madness if we did
nothing stops the spread nothing ever
stops us this Wednesday night I'm at the
I sell for less than 15 tickets left I
saw Steve at K calm Brian town is in
Vancouver County this weekend Saturday
come see me
they come to mix comedy a challenge of
honey mix calm is rating a tickets all
right okay I'll see you direct people
towards t5k fact if I would go right to
the soap right does it make sense tea
factory calm Bryan Callen Vancouver I'm
at the ice house Wednesday night I'm at
the comic store Thursday night with
Rogen [ __ ] Joey Diaz Dane Cook
a bunch of the people it's all over
through this at the comic store keep a
cave that conference means ever ever
needed ever this is the fun kid we're
out